lists france amber plus it should never
have been on the amber plus list
to start with you weren't even involved
in that decision making were you
well usually um as you know the
decisions are made on a three-week
circulating basis so uh the end of next
week will be the next
decisions on traffic lights but and
we've always said this it's
really important that when new evidence
comes to light
uh if it's uh of of concern uh we don't
sit on that information so
an out of schedule change was made for
france onto the amber plus list that was
because of specific concern about a beta
variant there
and of course if if we didn't act as a
government people would say
well why didn't you do anything about it
you knew you didn't do anything i'd be
on your program defending not doing
anything which would be crazy so
of course as soon as the information is
there the government has to
act on it monitor it and take the best
evidence and from the scientists which
is what's happening being economical
with the actuality there you say that
there was a delta variant in france it
wasn't it was on the reunion island
which is
thousands of miles away uh it's the beta
uh variant uh forgive me okay
the point remains that that's why you
put it on the list so forgive me i i
mixed up the
uh variants that was the reason that you
changed the list
you weren't even involved that in that
decision making it was the department of
health that announced it
well i say sometimes there will be uh
concerns department health obviously is
the lead department for
for these things and they will um act as
soon as they see a problem
um yeah the beast of aaron it's not just
uh as has been reported
on an island thousands of miles away it
was also an issue in particular northern
france
so uh it's it has been a a an overall
concern
and and look the big concern is that we
don't allow there
in which somehow is able to escape the
vaccine program that we've got we don't
want to have got
this far with vaccinations with just
getting towards 90
of all adults having been vaccinated and
then throw it all away because
uh a variant that the vaccine perhaps
couldn't handle
uh came in now all the evidence and all
of that um is being
pulled together the latest research on
um how the vaccine works with the beta
variant the scale of the beta variant in
france and the rest of it
uh and then these decisions will of
course be constantly reviewed which is
exactly what will happen it's
interesting because the french disagree
they
uh the europe minister clement boom says
it's excessive
and it's frankly incomprehensible on
health grounds it's not based on science
and it's discriminatory towards the
french
well look as i say no it's always
disappointing for any
country to be you know any anything
other but on our green list i i
appreciate that i spoke to my opposite
number jean-baptiste
just yesterday uh and we're we're agreed
we will always
try and follow uh we'll always follow
the science on these things
uh and uh and make sure that you know as
we can be satisfied over whichever the
variants are and whatever the prevalence
is
um that the joint biosecurity center
recommendations to us
are followed uh and uh if they tell us
there are problems then we need to
follow those those problems to the
logical conclusion but look i'm looking
forward to the whole world being more
accessible fortunately this week i've
been able to announce
um a effectively a big reopening ability
for people to visit here where they've
been
double vaccinated uh for uh most of
europe and uh and america
and so we're moving in the right
direction i know it's painful
but i think that generally speaking your
viewers
probably want csb cautious rather than
sort of gung-ho
on this and that's exactly what we're
trying to do i think what they want is
straight answer so let's try this one
google
netflix among others saying that staff
need to be double jabbed
before they can return to the office in
groups dominick rob was on the program
yesterday he thought that that was
a good idea what do you think i think
obviously being jabbed is massively
important it's important for you
as an individual but it's also important
for your your friends and your
your loved ones and for people you don't
even know who could pick up this
virus if we don't take all the
protections uh that are possible
fortunately in this country i know as
opposed to
uh in the u.s where where google uh uh
uh headquartered fortunately in this
country we have very little
vaccine hesitancy i mentioned overall
that adults uh
uh just approaching 90 percent of all
adults are
at first vaccinated and and 70 over 70
second vaccinated
so there's not much hesitancy here and
as we have just discussed
i mean there's only there's a two-thirds
of the youth
have been vaccinated up to the age of
30. so that's not true
a lot of these people will want to come
back to work at some stage if they don't
have two jabs
should they be allowed back in the
office yeah so so i mean it is true that
overall
all adults of all adults uh it's sort of
90
nearly 90 uh vaccinated you're right
that within the sort of 20 and 30 year
olds uh it's fewer that's partly of
course because they've been offered it
more recently
but they will need to get vaccinated if
they want to travel internationally
again
uh it's quite clear now that the path
it's not a question if you can just give
me a straight answer to my question mr
shouts that would be great
do you think like your colleague the
foreign secretary thinks that it is a
good idea for people to be
double jabbed and they should need to be
double jab before they go back to the
office
yes it's a good idea and yes some
companies will require it we're not
going to make that
legislation that every adult has to be
double vaccinated before they go back to
the office
but yes it's a good idea and yes some
companies will require it
thank you for clarifying that let me ask
you about the fact that whales are
dropping self-isolation on the 7th
of august and scotland on the 9th of
august northern ireland the 12th of
august
for people who have been double
vaccinated they no longer need to
quarantine if they're pinged
should we look again at the 16th of
august here in the united kingdom
in england we're always keeping on a
very close um review
the reality is um that people uh
putting themselves in in self-isolation
has been a factor in saving a lot of
lives
because uh it turns out that one in
three people who are requested
to self-isolate do end up developing the
symptoms um so it's
if you like the only remaining measure
that's being taken at the moment
because of course all the other measures
have been dropped at the
the fourth unlock stage on the 19th of
july it's the only measure that remains
so we're being if you like slightly
cautious
uh about it um but we have got systems
in place now where
testing can take place at 2000 different
locations
uh we'll have for uh key workers to be
tested
so that they don't have to self-isolate
in advance of
um the the 16th of august when we will
then not require people
to self-isolate but instead be tested uh
if they are pink or asked or asked
yourself
it's the 16th of august in stone for
england despite what the other nations
are doing
yeah right now that is the date we'll
always keep these things under review
but i don't want to open up false
hope for you we we uh it's not too far
away now what two and a half weeks or so
uh and i think um as i say it's the only
uh
lever that we have and it will be
protecting the spread of the virus but
of course
you know every day the the new data
comes out we look very closely at it
we'll adjust
um our approach but right now i haven't
seen anything which suggests that we
shouldn't wait until the 16th
of uh august because as i say it is
providing just that last piece of
protection
uh as we exit these various different
measures
of lockdown